good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Wednesday it is our favorite day of the
week week here at the toast it is hump
day the weekly reminder that it's so
important to hump someone you love and
speaking of humping people I love don't
touch me he never lets me touch her it's
Jackie hey Jax how you doing that is who
I am I do believe there was an
inaccuracy in your intro some
misinformation because you called come
to our favorite day of the week and I
don't think it's our favorite day I
really don't yeah no because like any
day that's not Saturday or Sunday is
never going to be my favorite day that's
a that's an amazing call I would say
okay well it's not my favorite day of
the week it's my favorite day to do the
intro how's that that's good better than
Friday Friday oh [ __ ] okay not you like
with your microscope calm down
listen I'm on the hunt for
misinformation as Prince Harry said it
is a global epidemic out there of Miss
info Prince Harry has said a lot of
stuff that too but like 45 other things
yeah he keeps saying stuff which you
guys will never know what he said
because if this is the only podcast that
you listen to We have kind of an embargo
on the situation so I feel like even if
this is the only podcast you listen to
you know absolutely everything that's
going on because there's like I have I
know everything about Prince Harry and
I'm this I'm getting fed this
information against my will I'm not
seeking it out I'm trying to stay far
away from this man who is really like
torturing me yet here I am knowing
everything
yeah we do know a lot and that's before
even like clicking on the headlines
reading the book is anyone even reading
the book I think is it the 10th oh it
came out yesterday it came out yesterday
I saw people on social media like going
to Barnes and Noble I saw people on
social media on Tick Tock sharing
Snippets of the audiobook because it is
read in Harry's voice and it's kind of
crazy like the audiobook parts for sure
yeah the way that it's written like it's
it's weird to me he's like PA said not
to do that it like reminds me of
crawdads like Jackie Howe said this it's
Little House on the Prairie like Paul
and I went to the Garden it's weird that
he calls King Charles Paul
right especially when there's a lot of
speculation he might not be as Paul
might not be his pop he should be
calling him either father
would be acceptable for me Daddy
that's very British very British yeah
um it's also just like weird I can't
explain it and I'm not going to explain
why I feel weird about it but I do
normalize just feeling weird and that
being the end of it and that being that
on that on that today's Wednesday which
means we have a fabulous show we've got
lots of good stories we also have deer
toasters where we're gonna change and
save lives which is just always a fun
thing to wake up and do
and I'm coming at you from my toxic
mother-in-law era and you're gonna get
some perspectives that you did not sign
up for no but some that's the thing
about the toast it's like we're always
giving you well-rounded perspectives it
used to be you know two wives but now
what's a wife and a mother-in-law
potential future mother-in-law God
willing
um and that means our perspectives are
changing and I feel like that's good
and the thing is at least for me
reels get ready
life is about perspective and it's all
about seeing your life through the
lenses of other people because that's
how people see you it's so true it's
called self-awareness and so many people
in our day and age lack it and I'm
worried for you because if you're
wondering like why do I have no friends
or why don't people like want to hang
out with me it's most likely because
you're not self-aware and you're not
seeing yourself through the lens of
other people like you're not seeing how
you could be annoying or rude or
condescending so maybe try looking at
life through the lens of like your
friends and family and maybe you'll know
why people don't [ __ ] stick around
yeah so at Deer toasters we're gonna try
and let you know how the world sees you
and I do think for the most part it's
gonna be hurtful no with these toasters
like we're usually team toaster but
there's the one in a once in a while
where it's like girl you're wrong
girl do you like my outfit I do so I
know you have a big interview today and
I should have kept that in mind when I
wore my boys lie set because you've been
like casual all week so I was like yo
I'll just I'm gonna copy mclared she's
so cool and trendy like in her mclared
era and
now I look like a slob and no you look
like a queen no let me tell you I'm not
even dressed nice well I was planning on
dressing nicer than I've been dressing
for my interview today but I told you
yesterday like it is literally 40
degrees here I packed like dresses and
[ __ ] I have nothing to wear and when I
was complaining about that on the toast
yesterday you know a toasty social media
manager from the brand rails was like we
have a showroom in La like pick a couple
things that you need for the week and
we'll just send it to your hotel I had a
whole new wardrobe by 5 PM last night
after the episode this whole outfit I
got a stunning cashmere set I had got a
cashmere sweater to wear to dinner last
night like I don't know what the [ __ ] I
was gonna wear for my big ass interview
today but I'm glad I didn't have to
think about it because I got this
gorgeous cable knit moment from rails
thank you that's really beautiful I I
kind of would like one
it's like just say something like I want
a Maserati and then I think the Maserati
social media manager who's probably a
toaster will send me one or she'll at
least reach out and send you like you
know a pin that says Maserati and say
thanks for the shout out and that's just
as good just as good um yeah no I'll
I'll wait and see if anyone wants to
reach out about that said I would love
one and if not I'll get one on my own
but I can't talk about the brand that
you're wearing without calling it rails
it's rails it and you know what it is it
is rails
Israel
I think I'll take a trip this year
should I go to Italy or Israel
what do you think
I think you should go to Israel do you
see the clip going around by the way
I've been sending you such funny reels I
hope that you're taking the time to
watch some of them I've been watching
all of them because reals people are
real people
facts she said it not me but have you
seen the clip going around from the Miss
Universe Pageant of all the country
girls introducing themselves
yeah yeah uh you know
Costa Rica whatever yeah and then they
keep going and then it's like France
yeah I have seen that one have you seen
the compilation of Bachelor girls who
were former pageant Queens doing their
intros Alabama
oh yeah but that's no offense that's
kind of like old
oh not the realest person shaming me for
not being on Trend reels are coming up
in the clutch I actually I don't even
know if you know what I'm talking about
with Miss Universe it's like really
recent well just to put into perspective
how behind on the times Jackie is I
think it's important that everyone knows
that maybe four days ago Jackie
discovered who Hezbollah was she sent me
a clip of Hezbollah and was like who is
this kid he's so cute I'm like he's 40
years old he's like a Russian UFC
fighter and he's everything he's at UFC
I did some research after
um he's like a really big UFC fan and
they've like welcomed him into the
family and now my algorithm on Instagram
every you know how like after every
three people that you follow they give
you you know someone that you should
follow all of those suggested posts are
reals and memes of Hezbollah and I'm not
complaining no you should start a
Hezbollah fan account like I totally get
the obsession he's I know he's like a of
Age and and he looks like a child
because it's an illness he has but he's
so cute
he's so cute the content is so pure and
then the people who like meme some of
the stuff that he does I don't know what
in what context he's you know chewing
and making that face Jackie
um I'm so glad you know about the
chewing Hezbollah meme it's the best
thing on the planet
it's the best thing on the planet and
that's my new internet Obsession I do
believe that I'm late because when you
said oh that says well like I had that
name like rang a bell from like you know
like the island boys on Tick Tock like
I've heard of it but I couldn't tell you
what it was no you don't need to believe
me like you are late it's just a fact of
life no I I do believe you because I
believe women yeah well nevertheless I'm
glad you're here
happy to be here you know the wheels of
Justice turn slowly
but they turn mighty fine
and the wheels of the toast don't turn
slowly actually we just pretty much
never have beat a joke until it's dead
but we've got a great show today I've
got such a busy day I've got my big
interview which I'm really excited for
people to hear and then I'm doing
someone else's podcast that I'm like
actually a fan of so I'm just like today
is actually the definition of podcast
podcast oh for me it's a podcast podcast
sort of day just a twofer two but still
um and you can tell that Claudia takes
these podcast podcasts very seriously
because not only is she wearing a
cashmere set she's wearing lopers yes I
am I've been wearing Chanel you see
these loafers Chanel what's that from my
comedy special disgrace Queen now
available to stream on Amazon Prime
that's the first comedy special don't
get it mistaken with n log and think
that you missed something yeah analog is
still in the editing phase but I can't
wait for everyone to see it I actually
just recently saw the first cut oh my
God it was cackling and I mean I think
I'm hilarious but I watched with Shapiro
Olivia and Ben because I wanted like
some thoughts when I was in Florida I
wanted their like take and you know
getting Shapiro to laugh like he's
really not my target demo so every time
he cackled it was like a huge win for me
I feel like Shapiro thinks you're so
funny no he does but like stand up is
very personal and like me talking about
like my fat ass and like my pop culture
like it's really not necessarily
targeted for him
yeah but he I think he's a big fan of
yours I think so too no I'm not saying I
didn't think he was a big fan no I I
never said that I think Shapiro really
likes you Claudia I think he's really
glad that you're his sister-in-law I
agree I would argue he likes me better
than you
well now we're really close because we
live near each other for him yeah you
both abandon the family you do have that
in common and because I'm Kayla's
favorite auntie so that's definitely
true and if I would feel bad about not
being Kayla's favorite auntie if I
wasn't Harry's favorite auntie so I'm
okay you know what Kayla you can keep
anti-sac okay yeah no it's just facts at
this point like we don't even have to
and now that there's enough nibblings to
go around like okay I'm Kayla's favorite
auntie you're Harry's favorite auntie
and Levi and the snitch have a
connection I like she's very calming
with him I agree and Olivia doesn't care
because like they're all her kids right
of course I love her the most yeah they
do love her the most which is kind of
like the cool thing about being a mom
you don't have to compete like when you
say like oh Harry's you know my child
like your child I'm like sure girl sure
you don't even know what we get up to
let me ask you a question is it like so
rude and annoying when I say like
Harry's my son
no
like you're not offended by it no but
I'm also just like not a wiener who's
offended by stuff such an important
distinction I'm so yeah sure like I
carried him for 10 months I labeled in
childbirth but like you love my son
enough to think of him as your own like
why the [ __ ] would I be offended by that
we love a rational Queen like we really
do let me ask you another question about
my auntie hood is there anything I do as
an auntie that like you
don't like like I kiss him on the mouth
I call him my son I say he's a child of
Christ is there anything I do that like
you wish I would stop doing like but you
would never tell me now's the
opportunity no nothing that I wish you
were stopped doing I think you're a
great auntie but it is like when you
kiss him on the mouth like it makes me
feel like I like I kiss him on the mouth
sometimes but he also always has a
pacifier in
um I'll take the passy out right so I
mostly kiss him on the cheek and stuff
but it maybe it makes me realize like I
think you kiss him on the mouth more
than I do
good
yeah it's whatever
no and when Harry grows up God willing
you know one day gets married hopefully
not
um and he's such an affectionate husband
he that girl can thank his auntie for
teaching him affection at a young age
it's true I'm sure she'll be thanking
you I'm sure the two of you'll be
extremely close the way I'm gonna hate
that [ __ ] like no matter who she is
like she better I know she's probably
like in utero right now but she better
watch her [ __ ] back okay no I I I
will be hard to please when it comes to
his betrothed but it can happen like
there is a girl out there that I believe
could be good enough for him
yeah me too Margot Robbie is she
available no I actually don't think
she'll be good enough for him no offense
like Hollywood's kind of gross yeah
actually so true speaking of Hollywood I
was here oh you wonder the craziest
thing so I'm in my hotel last night
maybe uh what time was it I got back I
got locked out of the room maybe like 3
34. and somebody walked out of the
elevator in like a major ball gown full
Glam like a team of people and I
remembered it was the Golden Globes last
night and she was probably going so then
I went on Getty Images I wanted to know
who it was I mean I know who everyone is
and I didn't recognize this girl
so I'm on getting images like searching
for someone it was a black
spaghetti strap dress with like a corset
top and then just like poofy at the
bottom and I swear to God Daisy Edgar
Jones was wearing the same exact dress
yeah and and the same hair it was like a
curtain bang pulled back middle part it
was not [ __ ] I'm telling you I feel
crazy it was not Daisy Edgar Jones I
know who that is
yeah
but it literally like it was her but
like there's also I mean I guess she had
a team of people so she must have been a
somebody but there are a lot of randos
fraudulent actors I completely agree no
offense like someone's partner happy to
be there but like they're not getting
snapped
so true
um well speaking of the Golden Globes I
feel like we could dive in to the Fast
Five get stewarded because you know the
Fast Five are extremely diverse today
we're covering a lot of different
categories you absolutely love to see us
diversifying our content
um so without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know yeah you and today's yeah
yeah today's episode is brought to you
by modern fertility knowledge is power
and when you know more you can make
better decisions for your body your
health and your future there aren't many
decisions bigger than having a kid but
for many women their fertility is a huge
question mark and that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple finger
prick you can mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get personalized
results within six business days those
results will give you insights into your
hormone levels your ovarian reserve
which is basically how many more or
fewer eggs you have than an average
woman your age and other important
factors that can impact your fertility
the results will go deep into what every
hormone means and you can also download
the results to review with your doctor
for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
for just 179 and if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get 20
off your test plus you can get
reimbursed for the test through your FSA
or HSA so if you want kids today or
maybe one day in the future clinically
sound information about your body can
help you make the right decision that's
perfect for you and your future family
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast that
means your test will cost 159 dollars
which is a fraction of the cost of what
it would be at a fertility clinic or a
doctor's office get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com
toast that's modern fertility modern
f-e-r-t-i-l-i-t-y.com slash toast
modernfertility.com
t-o-a-s-t thank you modern fertility for
sponsoring today's episode
thank you so much modern fertility
all right what do we got first Golden
Globes no actually because something
happened this morning that I actually
think is a bigger news
um in the grand scheme of things and
it's some Aviation news because
you guys the FAA uh Has Lifted the
ground order on flights after a two and
a half hours delay but they failed to
explain the catastrophic computer
failure that delayed at least 6 000
flights and halted America's air traffic
for the first time since 9 11. so early
this morning if you are on the East
Coast that you're it affected you more
so because we'll talk about Claudia your
personal experiences everything does
come back to you
um it really does but the faa's no Tam
system which Pilots use to see flights
failed overnight
um the issue was fixed by 9 A.M eastern
time but more than 6 000 flights were
delayed as a result it is the latest air
travel headache for the U.S after the
holiday travel debacle the Southwest
Airline scandal system is back up and
flights are resuming but after 6 000
flights get delayed or canceled then you
know those crew members don't make it to
the cities where they need to go and it
just continues to spiral so not only is
it a headache for all the Travelers
today but it's also [ __ ] fishy as
hell yeah no where's the explanation I
would like an explanation por favor no
explanation the White House said this
isn't a Cyber attack I guess just after
you know Decades of working it just
crapped out
right and so I woke up at 7 30 and I had
seen this article and literally I had
initially woken up at 6 30 because Ben
went to the airport so I called someone
like are you at the airport but you guys
the time difference is are crucial here
because 6 30 West Coast time is 9 30 a.m
eastern time which is actually when it
came back online
so I was like are you at the airport
he's like I'm pulling up why Nino Ben
doesn't know literally anything that
goes on in the world like there could be
a major like
attack on the United States and Ben
would have no [ __ ] idea like he just
doesn't exist on this planet I don't
know what he does all day
so I'm like uh is your flight taking off
he's like what do you mean I'm like of
course you don't know so I explained it
to him he's like I have no idea he gets
he took off completely on time totally
normal
well that's because his flight was
probably the first flight of the day so
it wasn't affected by cancellations
because the West Coast like had that
three hour window where they were able
to you know it was back on by the time
the West Coast woke up and he was doing
a very short Regional flight which means
you know he wasn't going to New York
where things were affected where then he
would have been delayed so yeah
thankfully the benefact worked its magic
but it's crazy that he was traveling on
a day such as today and so he's going to
Napa because today they're doing the
production Run for the skinny
confidential X Spritz new flavor it's
going to be a capsule collection I know
that the like the the fact that Spritz
and and Lauren are collabing has been
announced but I don't think they've said
the flavor so I'm not going to spoil it
let me just tell you it's a flavor very
up my alley and I'm very excited I was
gonna try and get to Napa today because
I want to like try and like be in the
facility and like take pics and stuff
um but you know podcast podcast couldn't
do it you can't do it all they say that
you can but you can't do three podcasts
in a day and go to Napa no you you
actually physically cannot so
I'm good that's it the flavor is up my
alley as well I think we all really like
the flavor yeah do you think Ben will be
able to bring some back for you
actually
that's a good less than three ounces no
because the good thing about about La is
they have jsx which is like a private um
it's a private Airline but you could
just like buy a seat on like a plane and
it's literally 200 semi-private semi
semi-private but you don't fly out of
like LAX you fly out of private airports
you don't have to go through security
and like you can technically bring so
that's what he's flying beverage let me
send him a text can you bring me a
sample
back did he fly jsx 2 now no no okay
because I was gonna say like that that
would be Jermaine to him taking off
successfully to me contributing to this
thing no uh they didn't have the right
like time for him but his flight home
was on the right time
got it okay cool so he could also bring
you maybe a can maybe a bottled I just a
finished product it can I don't know if
it'll be done by today I think like
production runs take a few days but
whatever
super cool
super cool you know the owners
and you know the owners so you'll just
be able to get that I do know the owner
of Spritz I think if I give a quick
handy uh you know later in the hotel
room I might be able to get my hands on
a new can of Spritz
spritzer by the way
um speaking of you being inappropriate
we did finally learn what smut means
okay what a Segway but nevertheless
continue I forget yeah you did find out
that smut which is what people refer to
those like porny Colleen Hoover books as
actually is an acronym for
sexually mature under text
something like that it didn't hit the
way I needed it to hit like when you
found out like but I'm glad that it's
that it stood for something as opposed
to standing for nothing which you know I
hate like why under text
it might not be under it might be a
different word that was the only word
that felt weird smut meaning you know
what that's what Google A is for
sexual maturity under text
like still makes no sense
yeah you're like just a personal
anecdote speaking of Google I mean
that's literally what the show is for so
yeah okay
good call
um through no doing of my own my default
browser on my laptop has changed to
Yahoo
and let me tell you it's one of the
worst things that's ever happened to me
in my life and like I literally went
into my settings and changed it back to
Chrome and it won't go away wait you
have a Yahoo browser or search engine
search engine excuse me I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry my my default search engine
has been changed to Yahoo and my life
has been horrible ever since like the
way I tried to make a Google form
yesterday and like I could not get to
Google form from Yahoo like Yahoo sucks
yeah
just a personal anecdote I wanted to
share in my podcast I'm sorry that
that's happened to you
and I can't figure out how to switch
back
Google it
rude
Okay Yahoo it I did and like I went back
into my settings and I turned it off and
it's not
that's so weird yeah honestly I
downloaded a VPN to watch the stupid
[ __ ] Eagles game on Sunday truth is
coming out ever since then my computer
is trash like I have viruses I get porn
like it's horrible
the truth emerges uh how your computer
just when they decided to be different
yeah no I believe it was the vpn's doing
got it
darn new VPN
are you ready for our next story which
is some Hollywood news as the Golden
Globes were on last night and though
neither of us watch
um there were some highlight moments and
some big Winners I will say I did watch
the first 20 minutes while I was getting
ready for dinner
um so I do how was the monologue
I miss that part oh okay so not the
first 20 minutes no like 20 minutes in
the beginning
got it got it okay
that makes sense
um so Golden Globes you know the Stars
some of them came out to celebrate the
Hollywood Foreign Press and their big
Winners so let's go through the list of
winners and share our thoughts great uh
best Motion Picture drama so that's like
best movie The Fable men's I've never
even heard of it me neither best
performance by an actress in a motion
picture drama cait Blanchett tar never
heard of it
best performance by an actor in a motion
picture drama Austin Butler Elvis that
was surprising yeah was he up against
Brendan Fraser in the same category yes
of course that was a letdown for sure I
mean I'm happy for for Austin Butler and
I saw this adorable video from backstage
of Kaya giving him like the biggest kiss
and hug and it was just it was beautiful
to see like two skinny Rich perfect
people like being happy I'm so happy for
them I I'm just Overjoyed for them
um so I'm glad we got that moment but
like dresses for Brandon pretty sure
yeah but I don't think Brandon Berger
was going to win because there's too
much beef between him and the hfpa and
he wasn't there and it's like I don't
think they're trying to punish him but
it's like they're not going to call out
the fact it's like a self-owned because
it's like then if he wins but he's not
here everyone will ask why he's not here
and it's oh because like we suck right
you know it reflects very poorly on the
hfpa I totally agree so a lot of people
say that like you know the Golden Globe
is a foreshadowing to the Oscar but in
this situation there's there's like this
beef and
and honestly I don't think it's a
foreshadowing to the Oscar to be honest
no I don't think it is I also don't feel
like the Golden Globes in recent years
have foreshadowed the outsources I feel
like people went at the Globes and then
the other people went at the Oscars and
then like by the end of the award season
everybody has at least one award it's so
true we're all winners here
so true so I'm glad Austin Butler got
his moment I think this is where it ends
for him I agree I mean he was incredible
and I do think like he's deserving of
the accolades I don't think the movie
was incredible I think he was
um but you know he did all this he
changed his voice permanently he lived
his Elvis for three years I'm glad he
got his silly little award you know yeah
did you see that people are roasting him
because he's still talking like Elvis in
his acceptance speech yeah no and I've
watched I literally like did research I
did like on YouTube looking for clips of
him before Elvis He had a normal voice I
was on good guys podcast this week and
we were talking about Austin Butler and
I asked Josh I'm like you know him from
like old school Nickelodeon days Josh
said his voice was not like that like he
had a normal [ __ ] voice
yeah yeah
best Motion Picture musical or comedy
the Banshees of in Sheeran I've heard
good things
best motion best performance by an
actress in a motion picture a musical or
comedy Michelle yo everything everywhere
all at once I love Michelle fabulous
Fab she's an IT girl I love it yeah
and that was a star-studded category
yeah then best performance by an actor
in a motion picture musical or comedy
Colin Farrell the band she's of Sheeran
then best Motion Picture anime animated
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio yeah I I
saw that I was I was shocked by that
and the title of the movie is called
guillermodo
listen I'm not gonna clown on that
because if I mean no I would do the same
thing Claudia ashra is the toast like
I'm putting my [ __ ] in there hey [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah totally I totally agree I
love your ashtrays you know the Revival
of hairspray because that's really what
my dream project is like I would put my
name on it Claudia's hairspray yeah
right
best Motion Picture non-english language
Argentina 1985 best performance by an
actress in a supporting role in any
Motion Picture Angela Bassett black
panther yes best performance by an actor
and a supporting role in any Motion
Picture key Hui Quan everything
everywhere all at once okay and his
speech was the that's like the moment
from the show that's going viral I
actually saw it in real life I didn't
see it you never saw a cuter [ __ ] man
in your whole life and he ended it
talking about I'm literally gonna cry
like talking about his wife
um how like she like always support him
he had like all he ever wanted to do was
be an actor and he was like Hollywood
didn't want me I could not get arrested
you know I think he might be like 40 or
50 and he was just so [ __ ] happy to
be there could not believe he won loves
his wife so much so precious watch his
speech it's adorable I will I've seen
some of the viral stuff from the award
show but I haven't seen that one yet and
we'll get to some of that stuff
then Best Director Motion Picture Steven
Spielberg the fable fable men's uh
best original song went to uh the movie
rrr so Taylor Swift didn't win and
Rihanna didn't win and Lady Gaga didn't
win so I have to say I actually I
thought I watched that category live and
the man who won was so unbelievably cute
and perfect and I'm so [ __ ] happy for
him
but the way that Lady Gaga is hold my
hand has really become one of my
favorite songs like one of my favorite
Lady Gaga songs of all time it's not
spoken about enough it's literally one
of the best songs ever written
I agree that probably would have been my
choice if I were on the hfpa uh and I
mean Rihanna showed up like that's
[ __ ] rude that she probably thought
she was gonna win
you think or it's just like Rihanna
doesn't leave the house very often but
like the Golden Globes I got nominated
okay I'll go to that sure perhaps
prestigious like the whole room stopped
and stared when she walked in they did
uh best TV series drama House of the
Dragon love that did you see that except
in speech because young Ray Nera did you
see her I didn't Claudia she was drunk
as a skunk up on the stage like holding
on to old rhaenyra oh who looked so cool
by the way everyone was quaking because
like she's so drunk oh my God I
absolutely have to go and see that I
miss that yeah
so that's one of the viral moments yeah
then
best performance by an actress in a TV
series drama Zendaya Euphoria and you
literally called that when you saw that
episode I actually
um I said that about Sydney Sweeney
no you said it about Zendaya the episode
where she's like running around oh yeah
oh yeah but I I did think that this
season was the season of Sydney Sweeney
I thought she was like her character
goes through like a mental [ __ ]
breakdown on this season and she really
did amazing I thought that she would win
um
but Zendaya was amazing too yes and I
actually remembered like that whole
episode where she's running around town
I did say that
yeah then best performance by an actor
in a TV series drama Kevin Costner
Yellowstone I saw
so deserved he actually wasn't there
because uh he had some flooding in his
home but
I'm so happy for him me too I feel like
we were just talking about how like the
awards don't really recognize
Yellowstone as like a premium show yeah
they really don't like it wasn't even
nominated for best TV drama right and
like I don't know what about this
particular season was so good that Kevin
Costner finally won
no it was just like he was too good to
ignore any longer right right
yeah then best TV series musical or
comedy Abbott Elementary that's
something I definitely want to watch
I've heard that it's a Content upper
would love it I know it's so much camper
like drama and the campers are so cute
and funny and it's exactly what you're
looking for like positive vibes it's
also written so well it's hysterical
yeah then best performance by an actress
in a TV series musical or comedy went to
kinta Brunson from Abbott Elementary
yes who's also the Creator best TV
limited series The White Lotus one and
then what I just want to skip to is
Jennifer Coolidge one for um
White Lotus as well as best performance
by an actress in a supporting role in a
mini-series iconic Queen we absolutely
love to see her doing the most out there
yeah her speech was really beautiful
really humble she spoiled the show for
me but you know what it's been four
weeks it's been four weeks since it
finished and I still didn't watch it so
like was I gonna watch it I can't be mad
about that honestly like if I was
desperate to watch it I would have
watched it I'm loving like the second or
third coming of Jennifer Coolidge and
what I think is so cool about this whole
Renaissance that people are having with
Jennifer Coolidge and she admitted this
and I didn't even realize it until she
did is that so much of it had to do with
Ariana Grande yeah like how Ariana
Grande really gave her like a platform
again like five years ago by doing that
impersonation and then like bringing her
out on The Tonight Show and like
introducing Jennifer Coolidge to an
audience two people putting her in the
thank you next video right right I think
that I'm loving what we're getting from
Jennifer Coolidge and the fact that it
started with Ari and the fact that
Jennifer Coolidge acknowledges that and
is so grateful is it's really a perfect
example of women supporting women
right and the fact that the creator of
the White Lotus is
another like added layer of Pop Culture
dreams that I just I I simply can't
yeah
so those were the Golden Globes
um if you watch them I hope you enjoyed
them
and that's out on that congrats to all
the winners
congrats are you ready for our next
story which is some wonderful news yes
bill star Demar Hamlin has been
discharged from Buffalo hospital and he
is heading home to continue his
remarkable recovery just nine days after
suffering on field Cardiac Arrest Demar
Haviland has been discharged from
Buffalo General hospital to continue his
recovery from home the 24 year old has
been receiving medical treatment since
collapsing and suffering or Cardiac
Arrest during the first quarter of the
Buffalo Bills Monday Night Football
matchup with the Bengals last week he
has shown encouraging signs in the last
few days and has now returned home to
continue his Rehabilitation there and
back with his NFL team
so is he going to be able to play like
is he
I was wondering that too like if so
probably not anytime soon I'm sure
that's not the priority but like what
kind of
recovery will he have like a full
recovery is this something that he will
always have to monitor and live with
also what happened they had yet to tell
us what happened and I feel like when he
is feeling like himself again maybe
hillshare because it's really not for
some PR spokesperson to tell us his
medical information right at the end of
the day like it's medical information
and that is private and everyone has a
right to privacy and so if we never find
out it's none of our [ __ ] business
yeah but the way that this has had like
the whole country uh you know just so
worried and concerned I imagine that
when he's ready to even when he even can
like physically like speak and do an
interview or something like he will
probably share again if he didn't like
will live but um I think a lot of people
are really concerned about what happened
yeah and people are invested in like now
um are like lifelong fans of tomorrow I
totally agree so I hope we we gotta sit
down I'm sure that we will but like take
your time relax go home be with your
family
yes 100 I'm glad that's the most
important that the story ended in the
way in this way because like it could
have had a different outcome yeah and
that now he can recover at home which is
much more comfortable than being in a
hospital and nine days after like
literally
your heart your heart stopping is is
amazing recovery and it's great
yeah so that's some positive news for
the day also I know it's not a story I
mean I'm assuming it's not because I
just saw it like breaking news on my
phone before did you see that um Shannon
bedor's boyfriend broke up with her I
did I considered it and I moved on it's
not story worthy but I just wanted to
know like what your thoughts were on
that I was felt sad I felt sad they were
together three and a half years it
seemed to be a good relationship Shannon
historically doesn't handle breakups
well right I feel like it's another
situation where kind of she invested
herself so much in this relationship and
like the rug has been pulled from her
though it's way different than David
like she's financially independent and
she'll be fine her girls are older it's
just different he's not the father of
her children but you know our girl
Shannon likes companionship so it made
me sad no I agree I couldn't have said
it better myself
Shannon even though I forget how I even
feel about you anymore
um I'm with you because I rode so hard I
wrote so hard for so long for her and
then I remember feeling like that was a
mistake yeah you did ride so [ __ ]
hard for her
yeah so anyways
what do you say to someone going through
a breakup my heart is with you
get well soon no he's TR he's trash
you'll be fine
yeah you're better off without yeah and
that's what you say
you're better off without him yeah
especially if he would do that to you
yeah right if he doesn't appreciate the
magic that is Shan 100
next story a little music news because
the Coachella 2023 lineup is here
everyone yes
and the headliners are Bad Bunny phone
chuckin Bad Bunny
black pink I literally did not know what
you were saying for a second I'm like
phone checking
um black pink my faves and Frank Ocean
are the three Headliners uh at this
year's Coachella festival with a lot of
sub Headliners so I'll read the first
the second line of each day because
that's like this the biggest ish so on
Friday we have Bad Bunny gorillas
burnaboy Chemical Brothers kaytranada
Blondie Becky G we'll be singing in the
shower and Metro Boomin cool then the
next day we have black pink Rosalia Eric
prids
Holo sorry it's really small text boy
Genius suicide boys kid Leroy Charli XCX
Labyrinth underworld then the third day
Frank Ocean Bjork Cali uchis Porter
Robinson Fisher Chris Lake a boogie
Dominic Fike Jai Paul
and then a ton of others oh and then uh
Calvin Harris at some point yeah
um so I was not planning on going to
Stagecoach and I mean not State judge
sorry I am going to say church I wasn't
planning on going to Coachella
I thought maybe if it was like this like
a Headliners that were tailored towards
me like maybe I would get there
um I'm happy for everyone I know there's
a huge Frank Ocean fans and huge black
pink fans and huge J Balvin fans So Bad
Bunny oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry Bad Bunny
fans so like I'm so happy for them like
I feel like that's like so iconic for
them I'm so happy to stay home
yeah I'm happy it wasn't planning on
going none of this is titillating to me
except for of course black pink but like
I'd rather see them in concert on their
own than go to like a whole festival and
like not even have good seats so right
I'm glad for the world that like there
will be more black pink and it's cool
because blackpink has performed at
Coachella in the past and they've really
like worked their way up to now they are
like the Saturday night headliner which
is so awesome that's so true like it's
such a big deal ice cream chillin
chillin ice cream chilling
black pink in your area
so good
um wait the last oh so people are like
quaking because it was reported and it
was like leaked at Justin Bieber was
headlining he's not
um so I think a lot of people were
disappointed in that
what's going on with Justin Bieber is he
okay
in terms of like Ramsay Hunt yeah
yeah I think he's just recovering I
don't think he's been like working a ton
I haven't checked I don't follow him but
until like the last he like made
headlines was when he was like suffering
from Ramsay Hunt like
and I think he's just been like chilling
and taking it slow
like could he headline Coachella if he
wanted to
I mean it's one night well two nights
over the course of two weeks so maybe
yeah
well if everyone whoever's going to
Coachella I hope you have an amazing
time
um and that this is the headline you are
hoping for me too
because it's the one you got good
because it's the one you got
our fifth and final story is some really
interesting influencer turn of events
Pig news oh yeah
so I want you to just sit back and
listen to this story because Story Time
jacks Story Time the gentle Barn which
is like a rescue center for animals
posted a tick tock on Monday uh saying
this about a pig named Pearl Pearl was
found alone in a field next to another
Pig who had passed away she came to us
with tattered ears and a potentially
life-threatening infection in her uterus
that has since been healed she's clearly
been through so much trauma that we
can't begin to imagine but she's now
safe with us at the gentle Barn from
what we've been told it's believed she
was purchased originally from a breeder
by an influencer people often buy mini
pigs or teacup pigs for clout online
believing they will stay small when they
inevitably grow very large and have many
unexpected needs they're sadly discarded
while we don't know everything she's
been through in her past we know her
life now is filled with friends
nutritious Foods the highest quality
care and so much love so then of course
it did not take anyone too much time to
figure out that this Pearl Pig was hold
on I want to get the brother right Logan
Paul's pig named Pearl he had been
posting Pearl like when he got Pearl he
even said himself like I thought Pearl
was a mini pig and then you know she
grew into a big old Pig and then this
update I guess you know also Logan's
fans hadn't seen Pearl in a while and
now we hear from this gentle Barn saying
like Pig has been through Dire Straits
right and Logan you know mistreated this
pig so I saw this yesterday and I was
like
oh that's really bad that's really bad
and like I and usually there's like two
sides to every story but like I don't
know how there's like another side to
this but did you see Logan Paul was on
TMZ explaining what happened I did and I
just want to say like this is literally
the Lucy Lucy Apple juicy of the
influencer world
yeah so then Logan went on TMZ TV TMZ
live and talked about his former pet pig
Pearl who is now being looked after by
gentle Barn rescue he says he owned
Pearl for a couple of years and gave her
a good life at his home in Encino
California saying he would even cuddle
and sleep with the animal and made sure
she had quote the best life but when
Logan moved to Puerto Rico during the
pandemic he says he sent Pearl to live
at a horse ranch in Santa Clarita
California because he wasn't permitted
to bring her with him Logan sells says
Pearl received amazing Care at the ranch
he then said Pearl lived at the horse
ranch for 10 months but had to be
re-homed again when the ranch owner
moved out of the state he says he was
unaware of the re-homing then gentle
Barn posted this Tick Tock saying that
the Pearl was irresponsibly re-homed and
found next to a dead pig Logan said he
only found out about Pearl's current
situation when the video came out and he
says he checked his records and he is
certain he didn't re-home the pig
irresponsibly he's also claiming
innocence on the second pig that was
allegedly found dead next to Pearl he
says the farmer denies knowing about a
second Pig and says Pearl was
transferred to the farm alone I believe
that I don't think that's sec I didn't
assume that second Pig was Logan's his
yeah no and this is so unfortunate
because I actually do believe Logan in
he did move to Puerto Rico during the
pandemic that completely tracks and I
believe that he re-homed it at like a
local ranch or whatever he did and I'm
sure he and I'm sure that place was
lovely
um I don't know if when you you know
re-home a pig at someone else's Farm do
they owe you an explanation if they
decide to re-home the pig I don't know I
do feel I actually do believe Logan I
feel like this is so unfortunate like
there is literally no excuse to abandon
and neglect an animal
but to put a hundred percent of the
blame on Logan I don't think it's fair
you know I don't think so either
I don't think it's really really
unfortunate
um and that this is what happened but it
seems like he tried to do everything
correctly and like so that the pig would
live the happiest life possible I also
feel like the gentle Barn like
insinuating that Logan discarded the pig
because it wasn't Minnie like just like
assuming and and putting that out it's
also like it's a rescue center it's like
it's so uh
they're so like magnanimous that it's
like why would I assume you're being
shady no by the way like their video was
like definitely Shady definitely like it
was weird for like an organization to
have like a video so shady and like
really not like they they didn't call
him out but like it was not hard for
people to put together who it was and it
did make it seem like this pig literally
left Logan's house was abandoned by
Logan like it missed a bunch of chapters
for being too big for being too big
which by the way that is a real thing
like celebrities and influencers and
people buy mini pigs thinking that
they're mini and then they grow same
with mini horses and then they grow and
they're like that's not what I want but
only a real monster would then be like
well get out yeah
you'll sleep on the side of the road I
don't I think like the the general
takeaway here is like people really
should not be buying animals that like
they don't want or need forever like if
you can't commit to like fostering and
taking care of this animal for the rest
of its life then like don't get it
yeah I mean but things do come up for
people say like you get a dog and then
you have a baby that's allergic to the
dog
of course I understand things happen but
like I feel like
Logan didn't need this pig
yeah well he did say that he if he could
go back in time he would tell himself
not to buy it oh great okay so he agrees
with Claudia I want to say I believe him
Tim
I just think this is really unfortunate
like Beyond
and he's pledged to help with Pearl's
Care at the gentle Barn okay good even
though they like [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
him like I know but like what else can
he do you don't expect the tone of like
the social media from an organization
especially when like rescues animals to
be so like like hostile and like like
drama channely you know yeah exactly
that's why when they insinuated that
like Logan discarded of this pig because
it was too big you just kind of take
them at face value because it's like you
guys are a charity like you wouldn't
just [ __ ] up yeah no the social media
manager there was like being being like
a little controversial
yeah a little clickbaity but this I
guess highlights the gentle barn and the
work that they're doing and it stress is
an important message but like the mess
it's hard because it's like okay so say
for some reason
you have to re-home your animal which I
don't think a lot of people want to do
but say that you do so you find this
wonderful Ranch acres and acres for the
animal to live amongst other animals and
then like you're like oh okay I'm giving
them the best life possible yeah my job
is done right
you think that it's not no that's why
re-homing is like not ever ideal
yeah and that's really what happened
with Lucy Lucy apple juice like directly
re-homed it to a good person to a person
she thought was good and that person
somehow re-homed it to
um someone turned a shelter yeah
um okay well we still have your toasters
our Wednesday advice segment where you
guys can write into deertoesters
gmail.com and we will do our best to
save you from whatever it is that you're
going through and we will always keep
your [ __ ] Anonymous so deer toasters is
brought to you by stamps.com January
means dealing with customer emails
returns gift card purchases and the
inevitable increases in postage cost
stamps.com teamed up with the post
office to get you huge mailing and
shipping discounts up to 86 percent off
it's a new year no-brainer for your
small business print your own postage
right from home or from your office
within minutes of signing up and you'll
never stress about finding the fastest
and cheapest shipping Solutions
stamps.com does it for you automatically
the post office is just elevated thanks
to stamps.com having amazing
Partnerships with USPS and ups for
unbeatable rates up to 86 percent off
stamps.com automatically tells you what
your cheapest and fastest shipping
options are there's no guessing no
overpaying and no overthinking it's a
One-Stop shop for all of your shipping
and mailing needs for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been an indispensable
resource for over a million businesses
you can get access to the USPS and UPS
services that you need to run your
business right from your computer
anytime day or night there's no lines no
traffic and certainly no waiting start
the new year by Saving serious money on
mailing and shipping get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale there's
no long-term commitments or contracts
required just head to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the home
page and enter code toast alright ready
for deer toasters
ready dear Jax and McClurg how you doing
I don't know what to do I'm happily
married for a few years now to my
husband who I love and adore I was in a
previous relationship that ended a few
years before I met my husband my ex
let's call him Baldi he broke my heart
and he left me thinking I'd never find
someone ever again imagine that me a
smart beautiful and gorgeous Queen
needless to say I did meet my husband
and we had a perfect wedding and we are
living out our cute married life but
here's where it gets complicated my ex
my ex is a part of my friends group and
we've managed to coexist in social
situations my husband knows we dated
previously we never really interact with
each other but neither of us were
willing to lose our friends over our
breakup so we just learned to live with
it part of me has always found
satisfaction in the fact that I was
married and moved on and he was still
single slash dating well now Baldi just
let the friend group know that he is
proposing and part of me is so livid
that he's going to get a chance to be
happy why am I being like this how do I
get over this also because we're in the
same friend group we were invited to the
proposal we'll be invited to the
engagement in the wedding thankfully we
will be traveling and we miss a proposal
but do I need to go to the engagement in
the wedding he did come to ours I just
genuinely don't want to be there but I
don't want to look sour in front of our
friends even though I totally am help me
sincerely a petty Queen
uh so first of all if this is a bad man
who's like not a happy person like he's
not gonna now experience happiness like
if he's just like rotten on the inside
so you don't have to worry about him
like being so happy and you don't want
that for him uh as far as not going to
the other stuff like come up with legit
ass excuses like book trips go see
family and then make it seem like it
just didn't work out there are ways to
not go to a wedding where it doesn't
look like you're being petty I agree but
I think it actually does look Petty if
she doesn't go to the proposal the
engagement or the wedding I think you
gotta go to one and you said you you
can't go to the proposal so I would go
to the engagement party like just get
wasted like it's a fun night out with
your friends I don't think you like
literally get something really
legitimate that that you can't get out
of for the wedding but go to the
engagement party like engagement parties
are short they're not like eight hour
weddings stay for an hour or take some
pics like be seen so you don't look
bitter you know yeah I agree so you
don't look bitter because
um I don't think you are bitter but you
sound a little bitter you sound bitter
but like I don't think it's because like
you're no I think it's because this
person like this person like destroys
you yeah and they don't deserve
happiness and like you can be happy in
your marriage and love your husband and
not want anything to do with this person
but also like still have a major [ __ ]
Grudge I agree like normalize like not
normally it's like Moving on but like
always like holding a grudge for real
like like human emotions aren't perfect
you know we're not perfect we're human I
agree and I think
you have to see like see this from the
lens of how other people would see it
like if if you don't go to any of the
events and like all your friends are
like wait that's kind of weird is she
still in love with Baldi no go to one go
to one look stunning and have the best
time like dance and drink and be the
life of the party and it's like the
worst thing that could happen is like
his somehow in your reaction to it like
no reflecting badly on you it's like not
only did he get a win but you took an L
this cannot happen no like by showing
how little you care
you will win but if you if you if you
care too little like you don't go to any
of it you will look better
yeah to delicate balance it's a tight
rope to walk but you can do it I know
you can go to the engagement you could
do you can do an engagement party I
agree and get a new dress and get your
hair done
for sure Jackson Claude hello and Happy
New Year I spent the holiday seeing all
my family like many others my cousin
Haley is in college and she's definitely
an interesting character she's worn
makeup for a while but she's never
really gotten it right actually she's
gotten worse her makeup is always caked
on it's extremely orange she wears white
eyeliner underneath her lower lash line
she doesn't wear mascara she also always
has fake lashes that are hanging on by a
thread and it's just a mess I know I
probably shouldn't be thinking this way
but I feel sick watching her in this
world full of critical and mean people
imagining what others are thinking of
her is there a nice way I can offer some
makeup suggestions she's also a very
flirtatious girl to say kindly I'm
worried she's getting a reputation for
her Endeavors on top of her horrible
makeup application I probably sound like
a [ __ ] but I just want to get herself
her makeup and her hygiene together so
she can have the best possible life for
herself I love her dearly which is why I
feel like I can't sit back and watch any
longer as her older cousin I wish my
aunt would help her out but she really
isn't into makeup and she just hates
that she always wears so much help how
can I help out my cousin without seeming
rude
oh this is Daisy because I'm the one
hand like bad makeup is a rite of
passage and like no one can just like
Snap you out of it like you have to come
to those realizations on your own and
then like look back and be like yikes
you know you're not gonna look back on
what you looked like yesterday and be
like oh I was all wrong like it's just a
part of growth so I don't I don't think
that you could say anything without you
sounding like incredibly mean because
like yeah she clearly likes how she
looks like
and it's her body her choice no and it's
really it's it's makeup is really
personal and like even though you might
think it's ugly and crazy and I imagine
it wouldn't be my style either like
whatever makes a girl feel pretty like
and whatever she wants to put on before
she leaves the house as like her
protective armor like that's her choice
like and it's her style and it might not
be your style but I think if you said
anything you would certainly not come
off as like the protective loving older
cousin you would come off as like a
[ __ ]
yeah you would come up as the people
that you're trying to protect her from
yeah
uh I feel like there may be ways if you
guys hang out a lot like where you know
sometimes like I've done Claudia's
makeup yes we do it for a vlog but like
you could try that like you could be
like could I try could I do your makeup
for this event like I just like love
your face I feel like I you'd be such a
fun canvas like something like that yeah
and and then she so she could see how
she looks with your idea of makeup maybe
she would like that but maybe she
wouldn't if she doesn't like she's fine
she's fine a good way like also like
maybe hire a makeup artist like you
really like and be like I'm getting my
makeup done for our cousin's wedding
like do you want to come and get ready
together like she can do your makeup too
like offer to pay for it
yeah but at the end of the day like it's
really not that big of a deal like I
don't know if this is a hill you
necessarily need to die on yeah it's not
that big of a deal she's not hurting
anyone she right clearly she takes the
time and the effort every morning to
paint her face this way like she must
like some version of how it looks or she
just it makes her feel prettier and it
makes her feel like safe and comfortable
or whatever it is like and and
maybe just gotta let her leave her alone
honestly
yeah or you could even like if you could
get her like a nice foundation for her
birthday I'd be like I know you love
makeup like this is the one on Tick Tock
people are saying like is the best
foundation like yeah maybe she'll stop
using like her orangey cakey stuff maybe
maybe she'll try it and be like nah it's
not orangey enough no I feel like
honestly you should leave this alone
I don't know like you could do you could
try a little but I wouldn't push it I
would get her a gift of a foundation I
would maybe like if you guys have an
event be like I got a sick makeup artist
like it's it's like two for one tell her
it's free for her you know but don't
push it because it's kind of mean
our third and final dear toasters is
kind of crazy
hi Jackson Claude big fan since the
breath my biggest Flex in this life is
that I went to Kim toast and I love you
guys my friend Mary has this boyfriend
named Josh Josh is a total Le Hooser for
many reasons but this situation took my
distaste for him to another level Mary
and I have a mutual friend named Taylor
who is casually hooking up with Josh's
friend Mike one day Taylor came to me
and told me something disturbing
happened in the morning before the
morning before when she and Mike were
together Mike got a video from Josh that
was of him and Mary having sex Taylor
was horrified and
lit him let him wait lit him up him out
for it okay she obviously she [ __ ] him
up for it Mike said it was a normal
thing
later Taylor and I told Mary what had
happened and she was really upset and
decided to confront Josh just brushed it
off saying it's a dude thing that it
won't happen again but Mary is choosing
to believe him and stay which I think is
is insane for a few reasons one Mary had
no idea she was being filmed which is
scary and illegal shouldn't she be
concerned about his sexuality this is
not a normal boy thing they are just
gaslighting us right any advice on how
to proceed is much appreciated I'll even
Center this episode if need be thanks
um what the [ __ ] uh like you told her
and she didn't do like care very much
the [ __ ] out she didn't care enough to
like leave do something about it she has
the information she's a grown woman
it couldn't be me but like what else can
you do if you want to send her this
episode this is what I'll say directly
to Mary Mary or whatever your real name
is um somebody taking a video of you
having sex with you without your consent
is so borderline illegal and it is so
insanely disrespectful there's a
borderline illegal sorry it is illegal
it's so insanely disrespectful it's
there's actually not not words for it
it's not a normal thing that happens so
someone who's supposed to be your
boyfriend and protect you and love you
and shield you from the outside world
doing that without your consent is not
somebody you want to be with and not
someone who is actually has your best
interest at heart then to send that
video to a different person takes us to
another level of betrayal and I don't
know if you know this and you don't care
I'm just saying like
I don't know what this man has on you or
why you feel the need to stay with him
and whatever it is like I'm sure you're
doing your best but I just want to let
you know like outside perspective we
don't know any of these people we're
just Outsiders this is so insanely
disgusting and disrespectful and like
you deserve better so if your friend did
send you this episode like
this is not normal like you absolutely
this is ground it's not even like a red
flag it is a red volcano it's so
disturbing and this and his reaction is
even more disturbing I don't think his
sexuality is in question I think
he might think this is like a thing
people do it's not it's not no it's not
and he's a loser for like even
wanting to show that to his friends that
gives him some kind of like I don't know
credibility any man who thinks that way
is uh not disgusting a man
um yeah maybe you're too far in it to
like see out right wake up like this is
no like there's no the only response
would be to end things with this person
like this is not a trustworthy person
this is not a good person
um this is not who you want for your
partner in life to protect you to be in
the weeds with you to potentially father
your children like this is not the type
of person you want on your side he's an
enemy to you yeah
yeah totally so oh my God very
disturbing
at least you have good friends who will
be there for you yeah
to help you get through this time but
this has got to end got to end
um thank you to everyone who wrote into
Deer toasters again that email is
deertoesters gmail.com if you ever want
to write in we will always keep your
[ __ ] Anonymous and you could write in
about pretty much anything that is our
show Jax it's been a pleasure thank you
so much it's been a pleasure though I'm
very disturbed now I know
thank you so much for listening to the
toast of the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify iTunes Stitch or public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places
whoever you listen to podcasts find us
the toast and leave a five-star review
about how
talented we are hope you guys have an
increa pump day don't forget to help
someone love and we'll see you tomorrow
bye goodbye